once you've built a quality app and
published it on Google Play
you've got to start letting people know
about it users have lots of apps to
choose from so you need to work to make
your stand out here are ten tips you
should follow to get more users to
install your app optimize your Play
Store listing your listing will most
probably be prospective users first
introduction to your app so make it
compelling start with an eye-catching
icon and add graphics that convey the
value of your app make your description
apt and succinct use the store listing
experiments feature to test the graphics
and text that drive the most downloads
and localize your text images and videos
your listing needs to pop take your app
global users prefer apps in their own
language so localizing your app can
quickly gain you installs worldwide use
the app translation service in the
developer console to request an
affordable professional translation of
your app and store listing
reach new audiences extending your app
to new form factors like Android wear TV
and auto opens it up to new users of
those platforms meet the quality
guidelines and then opt into each form
factor on the distribution page of the
developer console so your app can be
discovered and as your app suit its
family's education or enterprises then
reach those audiences too by meeting the
guidelines and opting in when you
publish your app in the Play Store
run app install ads AdWords is a
powerful and effective way to promote
your app to interested users when they
spend time on phones and tablets with
app install ads on Google Play Google
search YouTube Gmail within apps and
across the level of Google Display
Network you can also use conversion
optimizer to automate your bidding so
that your ads target users who are most
likely to install your app refine your
marketing with Google Analytics make
every marketing dollar work harder you
can understand which channels and
campaigns are driving the most visitors
to your Play Store listing and which
campaigns are driving the most installs
and with post conversion tracking which
campaigns are bringing in the most users
who take specific actions whether that's
making a payment or something else and
you can also link analytics with AdWords
to test which of your ads and creative
work the best
get your app in Google search by
implementing app indexing for Google
search deep links to your Android app
will appear in the Google search results
letting users get to your native mobile
experience quickly and landing exactly
on the right content within your app if
the user doesn't have your app installed
there will be a link to the Play Store
so they can install your app drive
over-the-air installs from your site let
users install your app directly to their
devices from your website with one click
implement Google sign-in on your site to
make creating an account quick and easy
then when users create an account you
can offer them an over-the-air install
which will push the app to their device
in just one click outsource for smarter
app invites add app invites to your app
to enable simple smart personalized app
invitations once you user invite someone
they'll receive an invite to install
your app that's context optimized on the
best Channel whether that's a
notification SMS or email you can also
deep link them to a personalized
onboarding flow that uses other products
like Google sign-in and Google Wallet by
including an offer or incentive to share
the app you can continue the cycle and
drive more installs
add an app card to youtube videos make
your uploaded videos on your YouTube
channel work harder at driving installs
add a merchandising card with a link to
your apps Play Store listing more views
could equal more downloads earn word of
mouth recommendations are priceless
they're one of the most powerful ways to
drive installs create a beta testing
group and engage your apps most
passionate users encourage your rating
or review with appropriate in-app
messaging build your social presence on
YouTube and Google+ and other networks
and reach out to K bloggers and media as
your user network builds you should take
advantage of the community by releasing
your app or app updated across
smartphones tablets where TV and auto at
the same time so an excitement builds
around your launch users can get in on
all their devices immediately and
remember wherever you have a community
or use marketing display the Google Play
badge that links to your store listing
so users know how to find your app for
more information on gaining users and
driving installs head over to the
distribute section of the Android
developer website if you want more tips
on how to improve your app or games
performance and how to build a better
app business check out the other videos
in this series and download the secrets
to app success on Google Play
you